[موسيقى]
هي فتره بشكل عام كثير منطقه فيها غموض
ومش مفهومه وفي كثير اسئله
[موسيقى]
البرنامج هو كان مشان نخلق تجربه ليليه في
الفتره هذا كان المبدا تبعنا وكان بدنا
نشتغل على برنامج اللي هو يغير النمط
السياحي الموجود
درسنا المهرجانات اللي حول العالم اللي
بتصير اللي خصها بتضوء وبين انه نحن بنقدر
نخلق موسم سياحي ثالث للفتره
بواسطه مثل هيك برنامج
البتراء ما فيها اي انثى
تدخيل المعدات تجهيزه معدات تامين
الكهرباء بدون ما نلمس اي اشي من الموقع
هذا كان او من اهم اهم الاشياء عنا انه ما
نخرب اي اشي بالفتره طبيعه الايفنت
والبيترا اتسلف كانت هي اكثر
تحدي احنا مبسوطين فيه لانه لاول مره
بتصير عنا على وحده من السفن بنكون
موجودين هون
قلنا نحن كيف ممكن نعمل فكره فكره ابتكار
نشوف كيف كل واحد بيقدر يطلع بفكر لحاله
ويطبقها على الخزنه ومنه كل فنان من كل
انحاء العالم بيقدر يجي ويطبقها بفكرته
فعزمنا ناس بالفنانين المشهورين من كل
انحاء العالم ليقدروا هم يفتكروا الفكره
ويجوا هون عنا ويعرضوا الشغل لاول مره في
التاريخ على الخزنه
لغه الضوء بتنفهم من كل حدا وكان كل واحد
يورجينا شغله كتير غير عن الثانيه تخيل
انه شو مدى هذا هذا المشروع
[موسيقى]